The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So
collective knowledge
got us a bunch more points.
So the rules for
significant figures
are on the back page of
the handout from Friday.
And so we want to think
about how many are
after the decimal point here.
So there are three after the
decimal point, which gives you
three here in your answer.
Log significant
figure rules-- yes.
So in base, and some in
chemical equilibrium, which
are all kind of
the same thing, you
can have subtraction and
addition, then multiplication
and division, and
then end your answer
with logs-- three significant
figure rolls in one problem.
Yes, it's coming.
So you want to get those
get those rolls down.
OK, so today we're going
to talk about solubility.
And this is really a direct kind
of growth out of thermodynamics
and chemical equilibrium.
You're going to be seeing
a lot of the same ideas
in solubility.
And then at the end
of the class we're
going to start acid-bases.
So far, we have been discussing
mostly pure substances,
and that is all
changing right now.
Because most substances
are actually mixtures.
So most of the time, you have
two things mixed together.
So mixtures-- you have
a homogeneous mixture
of something, something's
dissolved in something else,
and a solution is a
homogeneous mixture.
And so in your solution
you have a solvent,
which is the thing that is
dissolving the other thing,
and the other thing
is the solute.
So the solute is any dissolved
substance in a solution,
and the solvent is the substance
that does the dissolving.
And water is a great solvent.
One of the most common
solvents is water.
So when you have your
solute in your solvent
and it's nicely dissolved,
then you have a solution.
So let's look at
examples of things
that dissolve in other
things, and first we're
going to talk about
NaCl, common table salt,
dissolving in water.
So any NaCl is held
together by an ionic bond
and it forms crystals
where you have
these beautiful arrangement
of our sodium plus
and our Cl minus.
And a polar solvent, like
water, will, what's called,
hydrate the ions and pry
them away from the surface.
So if we look at this picture,
and we have our sodium
and our chloride surrounded
in our salt crystal,
we have water, which
is red with those two
little white dots, which are
the hydrogens on the water.
And so we have our bent geometry
for our polar water molecule.
And the water is coming in,
and it's hydrating the ions.
And so here, you see the
edge of the salt crystal,
and now the water is kind of
pulling one of the ions apart.
And here you see the ions are
coming out of the salt crystal
and dissolving in your solution.
So a polar solvent
like water can just
pry that crystal apart.
So stirring can speed
up this process.
It doesn't often
change the properties.
It doesn't make
things more soluble.
But it will speed it up,
because if you stir it,
you're going to get
more of that water
having access to the edges
of the salt crystals,
and helping to pry apart and
hydrate those ions so that they
solubilize.
We have an equilibrium
expression for solubility,
so we're just
following right along
with chemical equilibrium.
And so we have our solid NaCl
going to our hydrated ions,
our Na plus, that was pulled
out by water, and our CL minus.
And this in here,
it says aqueous,
abbreviation for aqueous, so
we have our dissolved ions.
That's how we would
interpret that.
And S here as for solid.
So we've also not
paid much attention
to phase of things at
this point-- a little bit
when we were talking
about increasing entropy.
We were talking about gases
going to liquids and solids,
and vice versa, and predicting
the change in entropy
for those processes.
But now we're going
to spend a lot of time
paying attention to the phase.
And so solubility, something
solid, going to its aqueous
ions.
So we can write an equilibrium
expression for this.
And it has a special
name-- KSP, SP
stands for Solubility Product.
And so KSP would be equal to
the concentration of sodium ions
and the concentration times the
concentration of chloride ions.
And equilibrium constants
are products over reactants.
We don't have our
reactant in this equation
because it is a solid.
So it doesn't appear in
the equilibrium expression.
So our equilibrium
expression, which
here has the set
special name of KSP,
is just those ions in
solution, the concentration
of each ion times each other.
All right, so let's
have a little practice
with writing KSPs.
And so we have a clicker
question on that.
All right, 10 more seconds.
Great.
Yup, so again, we
don't want to have
the solid in the
expression, and we
need to remember
the stoichiometry,
always need to remember
the stoichiometry.
OK, so they're
solubility product.
OK, so now let's think about
something that is not ionic.
Let's think about glucose.
We've talked a
lot about glucose.
Let's think about glucose
dissolving in water.
And here I have a
picture of two beakers,
a beaker where it's
clear, and a beaker
where there's a lot of
glucose sitting on the bottom.
And so we can think about
the solubility here.
So how can this dissolve?
It can't form ions.
It's not made up of ions
like sodium chloride.
So how does it dissolve?
Well, it can dissolve,
again, water molecules--
water's amazing-- water
molecules form hydrogen
bonds with the glucose and pull
one of the glucose molecules
that is at the edge of the
solid piece of glucose,
pulls it out into solution
by hydrogen bonding to it.
So again, it's
solubilizing the glucose
that's in this solid form by
interacting at the surface
and prying layers
of glucose molecules
off by hydrogen bonding to them.
Luckily, you know all
about hydrogen bonds,
so just to do a little clicker
practice, why don't you tell me
what kind of hydrogen
bonds glucose
is capable of forming if it is,
in fact, capable of forming.
But I kind of gave away
one of the answers here.
10 more seconds.
All right, good.
Zero put four.
That's awesome.
You were listening
to what I was saying.
Yes, so that is correct.
And if we look back at the
molecule for a minute--
so it's a hydrogen bond donor
because of these OH groups
all along here.
And so OH, there's an
electron negativity difference
of greater than 0.4, so it's
capable of being a hydrogen
bond donor.
But this double
bonded O here, it's
not a complete Lewis structure.
It's missing its lone pairs.
But it has lone
pairs on that oxygen,
and that could be a
hydrogen bond acceptor.
So we have hydrogen bond donors
and hydrogen bond acceptors
in this molecule, and water
can also be a hydrogen bond
donor and acceptor.
It has two hydrogens that
can form hydrogen bond.
It also has to lone pairs,
which gives it its bent shape.
So it can be a
donor and acceptor.
So it's capable of
interacting with glucose
and pulling that solid
glucose into solution.
So if we look at
these two pictures,
this could be glucose
[INAUDIBLE] in solution.
You can't see any glucose, but
here you see a level of glucose
at the bottom.
And a solution is
considered saturated
when all of the solvent has
dissolved as much as it can,
but a little bit of
undissolved solute remains.
So this over saturated.
Often it's just saturated when
you have just a little bit more
than can be dissolved.
You've gone past that point.
You can't get any more dissolved
in that volume of water.
This has a pretty large excess.
So sometimes when you
get your solution,
you get your solution clear,
your glucose has dissolved
or whatever it is you're
working on has dissolved,
and then you maybe add
a little bit too much,
and it all crashes
out of solution again,
you have the precipitant
just coming out.
So undissolved
solute, another name
for that, the name that's used
more often, is precipitate.
So it precipitates
out of solution
if it has too much in it.
So if you are not
part of the solution,
you are part of the precipitate.
That's my t-shirt.
OK, so dissolved and
undissolved solute-- they're not
doing nothing.
They're in dynamic equilibrium.
Just like all other kind
of chemical equilibrium,
there is no net change,
but the process is still
going forward and back.
In fact, the rate
going forward is
equal to the rate going back.
The same is true here.
The dissolved and
undissolved solute
are in dynamic equilibrium
with each other.
So how much can
you get in there?
How much solute can you
get into your solvent?
And that depends on the
particular substance
and its molar solubility.
And molar solubility is
defined as S. Either little s
or a big S. I've seen it
both ways in textbooks.
So the molar solubility, S,
is the molar concentration
in that saturated
solution, where
you've put just a
little more in than can
be completely dissolved.
And so that represents
the limit of the ability
of that solvent to dissolve
that solute, that particular
compound.
And its units are, perhaps
unsurprisingly given its name,
is molar, moles per liter.
So molar solubility is
related to our friend KSP,
but it's not the same thing,
or at least most of the time.
I think none of the
time exactly the same.
So when you're talking about the
molar solubility of either ion,
you're talking about that
concentration of sodium plus
or chlorine minus.
So you're talking about
the moles per liter
that can be dissolved in that
particular amount of solvent
or kind of solvent.
And so those concentrations
are the molar solubility.
And again, our
KSP is going to be
equal to the concentration
of the sodium in solution
and the concentration of that
chloride that's dissolved.
So in this case,
the relationship
is that KSP would equal the
molar solubility squared,
the molar solubility
of this times the molar
solubility of that.
So if you know one, you
can derive the other,
and you can do that on a
problem set, in particular.
So those are the
definitions of those terms.
So molar solubility,
how much of something
dissolves in another,
whether it dissolves it all
will depend on, again,
the nature of the material
and the nature of the solvent.
Are they miscible?
Is there a way, like
water, getting in there
and forming hydrogen
bonds, for example.
And this leads to a rule that
a lot of people tend to know,
which is like
dissolves like rule.
So if it's a
non-ionic substance,
then you need to pull it out of
the solid by hydrogen bonding,
if that material has
nothing to hydrogen bond
to, if it's
completely non-polar,
water is not going to be
able to solubilize it.
So polar things, polar
liquids like water,
are generally the best solvents
for things that are ionic,
like salts, or polar compounds.
So it doesn't have
to be a salt. It
can be a compound
made of carbon,
but it needs to be
a polar compound
so that the water
can get in there
and form those hydrogen bonds.
So you can see that knowing what
is capable of forming hydrogen
bonds can be really
useful to think
about what's going
to be dissolved
in what other type of material.
So non-polar liquids,
like hexane, for example,
are better for non-polar.
So non-polar like
dissolves likes.
And so that's why people
go to dry cleaners,
because you don't want to use
water to wash certain things.
You want to be dry.
You want to get your
non-polar stains out.
So this is very important.
There's a number of applications
of these principles.
This is important in the
pharmaceutical industry.
So we talked about some
of the molecules that
are used as
pharmaceutical, in terms
of being polar and non-polar,
and vitamins the same way.
So when you're
designing a molecule
that you want to get into the
body and react with a target,
if you design something
that is really non-polar,
the human body-- there's
a lot of water parts.
And it's not going
to necessarily get
to where you want it to go.
But if it's too polar, it
might just get washed out.
So you want the right
amount of polar non-polar
to stay in the body
long enough, but also
to get to where it needs to go.
So a lot of people who
are designing molecules
to treat disease are
very concerned about,
can we make this
molecule more polar?
Can we make it more soluble?
It hits our target beautifully.
It really destroys that enzyme.
It would be a fantastic
chemotherapeutic agent.
But we need to figure out how
to make it get into the cell
that it needs to target.
And of course, so if you're
going to go into drug designer
medicine, you care about this.
If you're going to
become a parent,
you care a lot about cleaning.
And it's a daily event.
How am I going to get this
stain out of my child's clothes?
Every day this is a question.
So this is important.
All right.
And one other example in the
longs of cleaning-- I just
want to share with you a
short story about a chemist,
Robert H. Black,
and a life altering
event that happened to him.
So one day, Mrs. Black said to
Mr. Black, clean the bath tub.
This was an unprecedented
event in the Black household.
So Robert Black went in
to clean his bath tub,
and it was really hard.
And he scrubbed, and he
scrubbed, and he scrubbed,
and he scrubbed.
And he was a chemist, so he
knew what kind of chemicals
you would need to
clean a bath tub.
You want to have things
to dissolve your likes,
so you want to have your
polar and non-polar.
You want to have
a chelating agent
to pull the heavy metals
out of the tub scum,
a surfactant, to make them bead
up so you can wash them away,
alcohols, to remove sort of
the more greasy kind of stains.
So he knew all of this.
But he realized that if
you didn't apply cleaner
on a regular basis, the tub
scum got so thick and so nasty,
that the cleaner couldn't
penetrate the scum,
and you need surface area.
These things work
by dissolving out.
They touch the surface.
So you need to have a surface.
So he had this idea that instead
of having this tub scum build
up so much that it was a
real problem to clean it,
that you could take
all of these things
that chemists knew
would be useful
and package them in something
that was a daily cleaner.
So he advertised these
things that, every time you
take a shower, you just
spray the shower or the tub,
and then you never have
to scrub your tub again.
Because you do a
little bit every day,
where there's not
a lot of surface,
so it gets it right
off, right away.
And Mr. Black and his wife never
had to clean their tub again,
because this resulted in sales
of about $70 million per year.
And it's important
to point out that he
wasn't using anything new.
He was just packaging his
chemicals for daily use,
rather than, say, for a
weekly or monthly use.
So I think there's a couple
important lessons from this.
One, it's always important
to clean your bathroom.
Two, you never know where
chemistry knowledge is going
to come, what life
altering event
will cause you to realize that
you have in your mind chemistry
knowledge that can make
you $70 million a year.
And when that life
altering event occurs,
remember that I take cash
and checks and stock options.
I added the last one.
I thought, cash and checks--
I should be more flexible.
So I'm also going to
take stock options.
And this is why I teach you all
the fundamentals of chemistry,
cover everything that's really
important for you to know,
because then if you use any of
it, you've learned it from me.
So just keep that in mind.
One never knows what life
event is ahead of you.
So what about gas solubility?
We talked about solids.
Now let's talk about gases.
So whether a gas is
going to be soluble
is going to depend
on Henry's Law,
or we can find out
about it solubility.
So a solubility of
a gas-- we're going
to call that little s,
that's our solubility--
is directly proportional
to the partial pressure
of the gas and a constant
called Henry's Constant.
And that depends on
the nature of the gas
and the solvent and
the temperature.
So let's think about this
rule in this plot in a clicker
question.
All right, just take
10 more seconds.
Awesome.
That is correct.
So let's just take
a look at that.
So one of the clicker
questions, which
is kind of getting
you to read the graph,
and so it was asking,
say at 0.5 atmospheres,
it said oxygen is more
soluble than helium.
This is molar solubility
versus partial pressure.
At point 0.5, sure enough,
oxygen is more soluble.
So that was just
reading the plot.
The other one was just
interpreting Henry's Law again,
that solubility would increase
as partial pressure increases.
You can see that
from the equation.
But you can also think about why
that's true, and why it's true
is the answer to the three,
that the solubility of a gas
is proportional to
its partial pressure.
An increase in
pressure corresponds
to an increase in rate at
which the gas molecules strike
the surface.
And that makes
them more soluble.
So again, solubility
really has to do
with getting at that surface.
If you get at the surface, then
you can dissolve your material.
All right, so why
should you care
about the solubility of gases?
And I'm going to
give you an example.
This is another
in your own words,
so we'll watch the video.
And I think tonight there's
some kind of big climate change
thing.
I've seen fliers around.
I haven't paid enough
attention to what's going on.
But climate change is
certainly a very hot topic,
if you'll excuse that right now.
I didn't really mean it.
It just kind of came out.
But CO2 is a greenhouse gas.
It's a big problem.
And so a number of
researchers here at MIT
are thinking about ways that
you can capture and store it
somewhere, get it out
of our atmosphere.
Other people are
thinking about ways
that you can change industrial
processes to make less CO2.
There's a lot of
research going on.
So today you'll hear from
Hector Hernandez, who
had a Ph.D. in chemistry
from the chemistry department
here at MIT, did his post-doc
here at MIT in chemical
engineering, and is now
a professor of chemical
engineering at Masdar Institute
in the United Arab Emirates.
So this is one of the MIT
satellite universities
that are popping up
all over the world.
So Hector was born,
I think, in Honduras,
and then lived in
Florida, ended up in MIT,
and now he's at the
United Arab Emirates.
So that's just
another example of,
one never knows what's
going to happen to you.
All right, so you can hear
from Hector in his own words.
So Hector's personal
video's online.
I think it's a fun one to watch.
There's a couple
things that are really
interesting about his personal
story, including the fact
that as he mentioned in past
life he did some construction,
he started undergrad
at age 30, I think,
where he was basically
building houses and fixing cars
and he realized that his
back might not survive this
being his permanent career.
So he decided to use his
brain instead of his back.
And so started undergraduate,
now he's a professor.
So it just shows there's a lot
of different paths to success.
All right so C02-- big problem.
We were trying to
use, in that case,
he was interested in
turning it into biofuels,
they were interested
in ways to store it.
You care about
solubility of gases
and you care about Le
Chatelier's principle
of driving things the
direction that you want
to make the products you want.
OK, so let's think more
about these factors that
affect solubility.
And one thing that's
very important,
for sure, is temperature.
So temperature-- most
substances dissolve more quickly
at higher temperature, which
is often what you want.
But it doesn't always mean if
you increase the temperature
that you're going to
make it more soluble.
You may just make
it dissolve faster,
but not actually
change the end product.
Some things are more sensitive
to temperature than others.
So most gases, for example,
are less soluble in warm water
than in cold water,
but with solids, it's
much harder to predict what
effect temperature might have
on their solubility, even
though for many things
it will make it faster.
So let's think now about
how to drive a reaction,
and what factors are
involved, and what's favorable
and what's not favorable.
And when we're talking
about those things,
we're going to be back
to our thermodynamics,
back to enthalpy, entropy,
and Gibb's free energy.
So all these have little
special sub names.
So when we're
talking about delta H
and we're talking about
solutions, things dissolving,
we're talking about
delta H sub sol,
for solution, or if you could
think of it as solubility.
And one point that I'll
make-- a lot of times
when people are learning
a new field, they're like,
oh, there's so much to learn.
But you get to some
point, everything
is just kind of like a subtle
difference in something
you've already learned.
So if you already
learned about delta H,
this is just a
slight modification
of what you learned.
You don't have to learn
a whole new thing.
So that's one of the good
things about the course.
You start recognizing, I
already pretty much know this.
I just need to add a
little sol to the end.
So delta H of solution
can be measured.
You can measure it from
heat released when something
dissolves, or measure
it by the heat absorbed
and at constant pressure.
And so the sign of delta
H sol will tell you
about whether heat is
released or heat is required
when something dissolves.
So a negative
enthalpy of solution
tells us that heat is released
when something dissolves.
And many of you may have
just experienced this.
If you're mixing
something together
and you're holding the
container, and all of a sudden
it heats up, then you know
delta H sol is a negative value.
And of course a
positive value tells you
that that energy is absorbed,
and sometimes things
can get very cold when
they're dissolving.
So you already kind of knew that
that negative delta H tells you
that heat is released, and
positive delta H tells you
that heat is absorbed.
So this is basically the same
thing that you already learned.
It just applies to things
dissolving just the same
as it does to any reaction.
All right.
Now, suppose we want to
know whether the reaction is
going to be spontaneous
at constant pressure
or temperature.
If we want to know whether it
will dissolve spontaneously,
what am I asking about?
What term do I want to know?
I want to know about
delta G. I sure do.
Delta G tells us whether
things are spontaneous or not.
It does with thermodynamics,
it does with solubility.
Delta G is to predictor
of whether something
is going to be spontaneous
or non-spontaneous
by the sine of delta G.
So entropy-- don't want
to leave out entropy.
Never leave out entropy.
My t-shirt's still
unaccounted for,
after they got back
to Massachusetts,
they left for New Jersey
and Cincinnati again.
Last time I checked,
they were still in Ohio.
Entropy.
So since disorder
typically increases
when a solvent dissolves,
typically, entropy
should increase.
And there's a little
star, and we'll
get back to the star, because
it doesn't always increase.
But typically, it
should increase.
So if we're looking at
these pictures here,
over here you have
your nice molecules all
lined up in your solid, and
it's going to then dissolve.
And you can see that
when it's dissolved,
that's a lot more
entropy over there.
There are a lot more
freedom moving around.
This is more constrained.
So typically, entropy
increases when things dissolve.
So if delta H is negative,
and delta S increases
when a solutes
dissolves, then what
do we expect about the
dissolving process?
And that's a clicker question.
Yeah.
So most people have, so
we'll take 10 more seconds.
So let's look at both
of them, because we're
going to do this one
in a few minutes.
So let's just continue
with our notes,
and we're going to
come back to that one.
I don't know.
Can we just leave that one
up, maybe for a minute?
I don't know how
long it was going
to take to me to get there.
All right, so when we're
talking about this--
we'll just keep
things in the notes
and we'll come back to that one.
So if this is
negative and delta S
is increasing-- so if this is
negative and this is positive,
then you're going to have
a spontaneous process here.
So if you can put in your notes
that this should be spontaneous
under these circumstances.
Now let's continue on and
think about getting around
to the next one.
So in some cases-- I don't
know, hopefully people
can see this-- in some
cases, entropy of the system
is actually lowered when
something dissolves.
And this is because of what's
known as this cage effect.
If you have water molecules,
when something dissolves,
sometimes order
around the thing.
And so the water entropy
is determining the process.
And have this new order
because of the water structure.
So this can change.
So it's not always the case that
entropy of the overall system
is going to increase.
So here, even if this
is a negative value,
delta H solution is negative,
delta G might be positive.
It might not be a
spontaneous system.
And so the cage effect
is why some things that
are hydrophobic, just
you're having a hard time
dissolving them, even if they
have a negative enthalpy, even
if you would just look
at the negative enthalpy
and predict that it
should be spontaneous.
Because even if this
is negative, if delta
S is also negative
because you have
more order due to
the water molecules,
then the overall
term can be positive.
It would depend on
the magnitude of these
and on the temperature.
This is actually more
slides than I remember.
Before we get to the next--
oh, this is the last one.
OK, so when gases are
dissolved in a liquid,
there is much less freedom.
Gases not dissolved
can be anywhere.
But when they're in a liquid,
then there's much less freedom.
And so the entropy then
is going to be negative,
and the solubility will decrease
as the temperature rises.
And so that brings us then
to our question about delta
H of solution being positive.
And now we can look
at the answer to that.
Now I guess we can go
maybe to the other slide.
So that was the question
that you had here,
and I've just put
up the answers.
So here, delta H is positive.
And so we have positive
minus T delta S again.
We weren't told anything about
delta S in this particular.
Just ask what if it's positive.
And so for the first one,
it said dissolving is never
spontaneous.
And that isn't necessarily
true, because you
don't know what delta S is.
Dissolving is only
spontaneous if T delta S
is positive and larger
than delta H solution.
And that was the correct answer.
If this is a big term here,
it's larger than that term,
and this is a positive
value, then you
would get a negative
delta G, and it
would be a spontaneous process.
If we look at number three here,
dissolving is only spontaneous
if this is negative-- that
does not help us at all.
And the rate will be slower.
Delta H is not going to tell
us anything about rates.
Rates are determined
by kinetics.
Temperature can
affect the rates,
for sure, stirring can
affect the rates for sure,
but delta H being positive is
not telling us about the rates.
So you'll see in
this particular unit,
when you're thinking
about solubility,
you're thinking about
equilibrium expressions,
especially equilibrium
expression KSP,
you're thinking about
partial pressures again,
you're thinking about effects
on the solubility that
have to do with
temperatures, you're
thinking about delta H,
delta S, and delta G.
So it's really an outgrowth
of thermodynamics and chemical
equilibrium, but you're
just applying, really,
what you've already
learned to thinking
about a solute
dissolving in a solvent.
So that's one of the
things that sets really
great about the course
and the next couple units,
is that everything's
very connected.
So we can just briefly
introduce you to the next unit,
and we're going to be talking
about acids and bases now
for several lectures.
And I have to say that this
is one of the units when
we get to kind of
acid-base titrations
that MIT students
seem to struggle with.
So we're going to slow
this down and really
go over it, and have you be
awesome at acids and bases.
And I'll mention that one of
the reasons why I spent time
on solubility and acids, bases,
because these are topics that
are really important for medical
school, and I know a lot of you
are not pre-med,
but I want everybody
in this class to have that
background that they could
go to med school
if they wanted to,
or they could just advocate
for their own health
with a doctor who doesn't
know about acids and bases.
And I'll tell you a story
about that a little later.
Anyway, OK, so acids
and bases-- we're
just going to some definitions.
So the simplest
definition of this
is that an acid is a substance
that when dissolved in water,
increases the concentration
of hydrogen ions, H plus.
Whereas a base is
a substance that
increases the hydroxide
concentration, OH minus.
So there are acids and
bases that definitely
fit this description, but this
is a very narrow description
of acids and bases.
The next one, the
Bronsted-Lowry,
is a bit broader.
So an acid is
something that donates
a hydrogen ion, H plus,
and a Bronsted-Lowry base
is something that
accepts a hydrogen ion.
And this is really
the definition
we'll be spending the most
time with in the class.
So let's look at some
examples of this.
So here, we have an acid.
And if it's an acid, it's going
to be donating a hydrogen ion,
and it's going to donate
it here to the water.
The water acts as a base in that
it accepts the hydrogen ion.
When it accepts
the hydrogen ion,
it has one extra hydrogen
ion, so it's H3O plus.
And when the acid
loses its hydrogen ion,
it becomes this base over
here, the same molecule
minus the hydrogen ion, so
now it has a negative charge.
And so you'll will
see hydronium ions
quite a bit, which is H3O plus.
That's really the
more accurate form,
rather than just writing
H plus somewhere.
So that's the kind of
true nature of things.
So let me just show you a little
animation of this happening.
I think it's kind of cute.
So here we have our water
molecules and we have our acid.
It donated a hydrogen
ion to these,
and then another water
came and stole it away.
And so there's our H3O plus.
And so in solution,
you have this exchange
of hydrogen atoms.
The acid is donating,
the base is accepting.
And as they donate
and accept, they
become different molecules.
So it gives rise to this idea
of conjugate acid-base pairs.
So here you see that
this acid is paired
with this base over here.
They're the same, except
that one has the hydrogen ion
and one does not.
And then the other pair is here.
It's another acid-base pair.
We have water and hydronium
ion that also differ by H plus.
So every time an acid donates
a hydrogen ion or proton,
it becomes its conjugate base.
Every time a base accepts
a hydrogen ion or proton,
it becomes its conjugate acid.
So the conjugate
base of any acid
is the base that is formed when
the acid has donated a hydrogen
ion or proton.
The conjugate acid
of a base is the acid
that forms when the base accepts
a hydrogen ion or proton.
So let's take a look
at one more example.
If this over here-- is this
acting as an acid or base,
this molecule here?
What do you think?
You can just yell it out.
It's acting as an acid, right?
This is acting,
then, as the base.
When this base accepts
the hydrogen ion,
it forms its conjugate acid.
And this then forms
its conjugate base,
which differs by H plus.
So why don't you try one of
these, then, on your own?
10 more seconds.
OK, so we can go back
to that over there.
So you most people
got this right,
and so you're looking at
what's acting as the base
and what's acting as the acid.
Again, the base is going to
be accepting a hydrogen ion.
So this is acting as the acid.
This forms it's
conjugate it and this.
And quickly, with the idea of
something that's amphoteric,
which is molecule that can
act as an acid or a base.
You just saw some
nice examples of that.
And finally, just one last
definition for acid-bases.
And we'll just put this up
and that's kind of the end.
So the final definition,
the Lewis Base,
donates a lone pair,
whereas a Lewis Acid
accepts such electrons.